boeing is stepping up efforts to
convince airlines it is safe to fly
there is 737 max eight jets again but
contentious hearings on Capitol Hill
left unanswered questions about the
grounded jets and whether the FAA will
change the way it certifies planes is
safe to fly Kris Van Cleave is at
Washington Reagan National Airport with
more on this joy Chris good morning to
you good morning senators push the
acting FAA Administrator about the cozy
relationship between the agency and
Boeing but that is a system that's
mandated by Congress the FAA says if it
had to approve new airplanes all on its
own it would require an additional staff
of 10,000 new employees at an additional
cost of 1.8 billion dollars a year you
don't think that they should have been
mandatory is that what you're saying
senators demanded answers about how the
Boeing 737 max was approved to fly in
the hotseat acting FAA Administrator Dan
Elwell promised the grounded max will
only return to the skies when it is
deemed safe following two deadly crashes
US and international operators of the
737 max are relying on the FAA to get it
right Texas senator Ted Cruz said the
hearing is just the beginning my hope is
we will get these planes back in the air
when we can be confident that they are
safe and they're not endangering the
safety of the flying public and that's
the purpose of the investigation that's
the purpose of this hearing you're not
there yes or no not remotely the 737 is
a safe airplane in Washington State
Boeing hosted 200 pilots and staff from
Airlines explaining software changes
it's making to the 737 max Boeing will
also require additional pilot training
American Airlines 737 fleet captain
roddy Guthrie attended the seminar what
they've done and what was explained to
us today in detail and our significant
enhancements to the system boeing says
these changes will essentially make it
harder for that controversial anti-stall
system to operate now what it will do is
it will rely now on two sensors instead
of one it will only activate once not
repeatedly and it will be easier for the
pilots to override it also boeing says
it is adding a warning light to the
cockpit that would let pilots know if
the sensors were in disagreement or
malfunctioning that used to be in an
additional feature that cost or
$80,000 scale well safety is always a
very important thing whatever they need
to do to figure it out the flying public
appreciates this Chris let's talk about
the Iceland based airline Wow it's
called we hear that it's shut down so
what does that mean for people that have
reservations with Wow well Wow is a
discount carrier offering fares to
Europe from four US cities for as low as
a hundred bucks this shutdown will
strand thousands of Flyers around the
world if you have a reservation the best
option for you is to call your credit
card company and try to get a refund
that way also if you're flying wow and
you're stuck somewhere airlines
typically will offer your offer rescue
fares those will be discounted fares to
get you home but you'll still have to
come up with money out of your pocket
Gail well not so Wow today thank you
very much Chris still a head scratcher
why some of these safety features were
optional right I do chide you don't
understand what I was thought process
was there it's not like you're paying
extra for leather seats or never finding
or the towels yes it is unbelievable so
I guess we'll hear more about that in
the investigation